so you're telling me you're on fun not
and you're on Wizards no no fun is real
Wizards are fake no no they're both real
funu is a real thing with buyers and if
the staircase is coming out the door
that means the money is running out of
the house and they're going to go broke
somebody lived in this house for 40 50
years all their money went out the door
this situation right here if Flip or
Flop the last clip that we saw it's not
like she so happens to walk up and tell
them about the wizard that she was
seeing no it doesn't work like that it's
like hey so what have you been up to
lately oh you saw a wizard that'll be
kind of a fun segment let's put that in
there what's up guys how are you guys
doing welcome back to another LED live
if you've ever seen anything from TLC
HGTV any shows about Gordon ramsy or The
Bachelor or any reality TV you should
definitely tune in because you're going
to to expose some Darkness today with
the Light of Christ wow so I'm actually
kind of shocked that we're exposing
hgv I did not know you didn't know was
satanic I guess nothing's aw in this
that's right yeah so so this whole idea
for this show started because I enjoy
watching HGTV you said your wife Flex
watching it too and you know what do you
guys think of when you think of HGTV
home and gardening yeah building yeah
like home renovations and stuff like to
decorate your living room they
on no that's the food networ it stands
for home gardening TV that's right I
knew
that so like you said it stands for home
and gardening TV so I I like watching
like house flipping and you know like
someone is hiring an interior designer
and they get a whole new home and all
that kind of stuff and so I liked
watching Flip or Flop tar elmusa
Christina used to Bea real quick what is
it about what's a flip house flipping
okay buying a house fixing it up selling
for sell it for a profit they've been
around for Seasons they're like really
well-known celebrities in this like
field um now they got a divorce Flip or
Flop
stopped T alusa got two new shows one
with his new wife and Christina Halls
she branched off with interior design
and she's got a show called Christina on
the coast which is where she does this
kind of stuff in California where she's
from and she does a Christina in the
country because she bought a house I
guess near Nashville and now is doing
home interior design in that area and so
I liked watching her shows as well and I
came across something interesting so
let's take a
look all right come on doggies let's go
I'm excited to figure out what's going
on with these guys today we're headed to
Laguna Beach to the Shocker Shack to
meet with the pet Communicator that way
we can understand our dogs better I can
understand Chella just fine if this
helps understand cash I'm all
in hi hey hi welcome in I'm Taylor hi
Taylor nice to meet you I'm dur hi
Christina Christina hi me you and this
is Stella
Stella's make a little nervous come this
way we've never done this before I'm an
empathic healer and so the the reason
why I can read dogs is because you know
dogs have feel feelings thoughts they
have personalities and it really is eye
opening to know where they're coming
from on the inside because I've seen
people just make even small adjustments
and have the behavior
change since we Blended dog families he
barks his head off at every little noise
and he'll literally be barking as he's
even walking towards me and like sees me
but he won't stop I was hoping that I
could hold him just so I could tune into
him he loves attention oh sorry oh he's
like oh this is a different
perspective so cash when I tune into him
I almost want to cry my heart gets heavy
and I feel like that there's a like a
barrier like he's losing you like he he
definitely feels like he's lost his
place but he actually feels like I don't
know if it's territorial or that like he
has to constantly prove himself or get
attention because he feels like he's
being put in the in the background in
some way
man what people believe this j i I'm not
shocked by the content that's ever on TV
anymore but are you kidding me like a
dog reader you know what I mean like so
so think about this right you come to
HDTV to watch home renovation and design
and gardening and stuff and so I
understand that in reality TV and you've
worked in reality TV they did they put
sections in there to kind of portray the
character you know cuz it's a storyline
right to bring about a drama yeah get to
know them that get to know them
personally and and and you'll see later
on she actually is into this kind of
stuff in a personal life but again like
if you are going into this completely
off guard and all of a sudden you start
seeing this kind of stuff it's like why
why is this in there I I I think it goes
and centers back in the whole age-old
when you see it you become familiar with
it and you're going to accept that as as
that's normal and so you know normal
family I think that TV show that came
out right you're putting this like
really like broken whack job of a family
mated together Modern Family same sort
of thing and then all of a sudden look
at our families today we're just falling
apart because we don't have the models
that we should have and so when I see
this it's like I don't know if they went
with enough intentionality of like we're
going to do a show here and hopefully
that'll influence people I don't know if
it's like that complex but I'll tell you
what the devil does does he knows you
know like putting this out there just
normal people do this yeah like at TV
used to have some kind of moral morality
to it like uh Lucy and her husband
didn't even sleep in the same bed
which I mean that's yeah that's not
really moral thing but they're trying to
you know not expose families and
children to a sexual scene or whatever
and then you had like leave at the
beaver and um Andy G I was about to say
Andy they go to church and they you know
you shouldn't lied and all this stuff
and now you got just the trash that's
out there today where it's just like
yeah let's practice witchcraft together
and yeah and then like the dad is you
know he hates his wife and he dreads
going home and the wife is the wears the
pants and the kids are rebellious and on
drugs and coming out of the closet and
that's looked at as oh this is normal we
we we talked about on this show um
Elemental do you guys remember that
pizar movie in the first few minutes of
that whole entire cartoon the mother is
a palm reader wow and you know you think
about that it's just like you know if
the parents are watching this the kids
are watching that and it's like you're
constantly bombarded by this like you
can speak to the spirits how can this
not affect society right you're saying
that the producers may not have had the
intention we don't know of yeah we're
going to influence these people by
showing the segment of her life devil
may have what do you think they may have
been thinking because was the show
tanking did they need to show this part
of her life you would think if it's a
topical show about Home Improvement why
not stick to the topic because you have
an audience that have interest in that
so living in Los Angeles for 10 years
you rub shoulders with all kinds of
different people and a lot of people are
into this kind of stuff that's true and
so I think it's just the nature of these
guys are the ones with the microphone
these guys are the ones with the video
cameras and they're putting out what
their world view is because lots of them
are into that so I would guess that
probably some of the production crew her
other people are probably really into
that and this is just normal to them and
so they're putting to like Duck Dynasty
and what happens is society begins to
watch this which is not a realistic
picture of what's really going on it's
just this is what's into Los Angeles if
you did the show in the South maybe
they'd be going to church you know me
well is it also a business exchange like
maybe the shockra shack reach out to
them and say hey I'll pay you x amount
of money can I on your show when I
worked in reality television cuz I
worked for Animal Planet as well and did
some dog shows um I was on a uh worked
on a uh show called groomer has it and
we shot in a lot of like dog shops and
things like this um no they want to be
on TV so it's good for their business so
I'm guessing I I think HDTV is probably
one of the more low lower totem pole
ones they might they might have more
because of Chip and Joanna and stuff but
um usually they're working on shoestring
budgets in Hollywood terms she was
saying the business would pay for
promotion like hey
I don't I don't remember ever a business
paying the production it would be more
or less like you know the production
calling them can we do a show at your
place and they would say yes you know
obviously they want to do that so you
could think okay well this is just a
oneoff right like she just went to see a
dog whisper but it's not um I've got a
few more Clips in there just throughout
her show uh some things where she seems
to be into a lot of new age spiritualism
Etc so Christina's let me know that you
need some stress relief in your life yes
absolutely and I do a lot of different
things so when I first worked with
Sheila I told her that I was having
trouble getting pregnant and that I had
you know polycystic ovaries and Sheila
told me she could get me pregnant and 6
days later I conceived Hudson I know
that some people are going to think that
all this is a bit out there but let me
tell you it works you just have to be
open to it tell that Cassie is a little
bit nervous about all of this but once
she feels the results she'll be 100% in
so how does that feel Can You Feel the
difference with just the two needles mhm
she's gone I feel more
centered welcome to Goat yoga you ready
to do this everybody child's pose knees
nice and wide we got to keep our tummies
tight so that when they land on us we
protect ourselves okay here we go
release the
animals okay guys last pose we are going
to
Bow good job you
guys
[Music]
but bye pushing this space back five six
F feet we extended the family room by a
huge amount it felt claustrophobic in
here before we had that awkward tiny TV
situation going on now we have this
massive television we have all this
storage we have beautiful floating
shelves like it feels like a model home
now I am so happy you guys did that we
needed it so
[Music]
bad this looks amazing this is
incredible it's incredible right as we
walk in the front door it was just a
full transformation like I can't believe
it's our house looks so big remember the
first time I came in you guys had a
major storage issue we had all the toys
in here now it feels like an adult space
we have all this storage and these
beautiful cabinets I love that could
just put all their toys in there I don't
have to see it such a game
changer the past few months it's been
intense our only Spa literally it looks
similar to the kitchen but it's still so
different I think it looks beautiful I
like the fuc is coming out and then it
breaks up the tile I am so glad that we
went with these counters it just keeps
it like really clean and again cohesive
with downstairs I love it and you have
your own makeup
[Music]
area
okay can we just talk about this for a
second y so for 9 years I was here I
mean I can keep things all in these
drawers this is amazing and I get to do
my my makeup I'm like so excited I love
this SP okay so before I go Sabrina has
a little surprise for you if you notice
this speaks to every uh like kind of
person that probably is in Hollywood
they're into this kind of stuff that's
why they're decorating with the
everywhere it's everywhere she's wearing
beads I mean there's there's a lot of
things that are very typical with like
Buddhism the gonging the all that kind
of stuff but but that's so common there
wait wait but so are the people that
she's decorating for do they keep all
those things or is it just there for
product placement or like just for the
shot or yeah sometimes they're staging
them and there's actually companies that
will show up at your house and Stage
your house to sell your house it's kind
of and all that stuff but she she this
is her interior design they're her to do
this so I don't know if they be her
budget that she said I got 10 grand what
can you do which is why she can put so
much of herself into it and then it'll
be removed and they'll be left with the
furniture that's the question is like
are the crystals being removed or she
just leaving them for them to do
whatever they want with it I don't know
it's like she literally just said you
know what would make your house better a
crystal in every room it just needs a
CST two per room yeah and and so as in
like we were talking about influence on
society she's an influencer what she's
doing is saying I'm a celebrity what I
say is the norm and she's like I know
this might seem a little weird but it
works yeah she you have an influential
person saying it doesn't matter if it's
weird it works I can get pregnant yeah
yeah but when they when she was with the
yoga instructor or the
acupuncturist the acupuncturist was like
oh do you feel it yet do you feel it it
kind of reminded me of like the placebo
pill some take Dr for the first time I
think I feel I'm not sure like you feel
yes like you know it's always this
feeling thing and then if you don't feel
it you might think that's maybe you're
doing something wrong or maybe your mind
makes you start feeling things that's
what's supposed to happen compl opposite
of Christianity number one and number
two you see how it's a slippery slope
but also a community is building where
people want to join and be a part of
that and feel whatever is being felt by
the influencer right right and and what
if she did now she can get pregnant
that's proof to her this works this is
but we know in the last days the same is
going to be performing miracles signs
and wonders and that's what the the
whole falling away in the last days is
because of what people are seeing and
experiencing with miraculous signs and
wonders you know I I think chip and
Joanna are Christian right they are
Christian these people I are Christian
and I think they do have some Christian
little bits are I haven't watched that
show in years I watched it I wasn't
really overtly Christian or anything but
they show like like crosses and things
in there no I don't think so but they
out side of a show they speak openly
about being Christian and they they
moved their show from HGTV to their own
channel called Magnolia TV or something
but they don't make it about or the
segments about kind of Christianity so
so I I just want to throw that out there
that this is interesting well this is
interesting that people if you had
crosses on here and bibles on the table
people be like why why are you shoving
that down my
throat yeah hear this stuff she's
constantly pushing budha ideas out there
and what nobody nobody blinks an eye no
yeah that's the way it is it's such a
biased Twisted thing when people are
like stop shoving your religion down my
throat and they're only talking about
Christianity but Harry Potter's pushing
witchcraft let's be fair I would agree
with that statement of don't push this
down your throat let's not do that but
then you can't just do that with with
the Christianity but not not not do that
with the world you should call them why
you doing yoga on your show I don't want
to watch your religion I want to see you
flip a house or whatever yeah yoga is a
religion so so when I watched this I was
kind of thinking like what about o other
reality TV shows specifically ones where
you least expect it right where you go
to watch these shows because they seem
like really kosher wholesome shows and I
want to watch this because I think it's
safe for my family so it's not the case
where okay you just won't watch this but
you watch another show on HGTV and it's
fine HGTV TLC I mean I'm talking about
the bachelor which but the bachelor you
wouldn't watch because it's wholesome
but I mean you you're watching it
because it's it's uh dating right you're
not watching it
love love but but it's not you're not
expecting or going there for those
reasons so let's take a look so in one
word what are you looking for in a
relationship with Zach one word just one
second just but think of that first
please tell everyone I was safety safety
mhm and the second one was comfort Z can
you just read this to me yeah what was
it safety and comfort that's weird
excuse my language I'm sorry I apologies
for the profanity but what in the world
that's the power of mentalism you can't
hide anything from
[Music]
me
now they're
gone and you're
mine I can't believe you're going to be
in room room 16 why cuz room 16 has a
ghost in
it this woman told me who went to room
16 she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets off her all night long and you
haven't been drinking Cherry no wow
Betty is a ghost at the Curtis house and
people do tell us that she raises a
little bit of Havoc with them she's
definitely
there room
16 a haunted room my goodness
me right go downstairs have a
look babe let me
out honestly it must be the bloody ghost
come on Betty let me out I just want to
get some
lunch I'm Glenn and I'm dagma and we are
both psychic mediums the energy of this
reading I can already feel it Glenn and
I met in England at a college for medium
midm morning he comes up to me and
says Hi I don't believe we've had the
chance to work together at the same time
he's shaking my hand I'm hearing my
spirit team say to me this is the man
that you're going to marry after living
in Melbourne Australia for the last 3
years the couple has decided to relocate
with their cat Grace to Southern
California is there anything else in the
house that's original I got something
for
you and you think of all the people that
lived here and I always go into old
houses oh oh my
God I don't believe in ghost but I just
saw a shadow over there was like whoa
let's get the hell out of
here Vicky H I'm a little bit nervous
I'm not going to lie Dean hi I'm
bringing in a medium Vicki SMI I feel
there are ghosts in the estate my mom's
H things we had other family members
that had weird experiences Dean doesn't
believe in anything but sometimes there
are things that you cannot
explain go do family yoga for the first
time how is it that y'all go to school
with ponytails and y'all never have them
when you come home we've been helping
Parker work through anxiety a lot more
since we took her to see the
occupational therapist and the OT
recommended something that could
actually help with her relaxation and
her confidence kids
yoga we've been recording podcasts all
day and tonight we're interviewing a
sidekick medium hey guys this is Kay
Lindsay with coffee combos podcast and
we are here late night with Monica the
medium I'm just going to open it up to
Spirit so this is what happens when I
start to channel spirit I turn all red
my ears turn red you look fine I start
to like I can't catch my breath and a
lot of things are happening so sorry
this is what starts to
happen
do you have children yeah uh I was
getting a three connection here but I do
get four so I do feel like there might
be one more child for you um do you
really want a girl yeah yeah I hate to
say this but it might be a boy again are
you guys ready hey Alex yes come on are
you guys ready yeah I'm ready go try out
our first session of yoga I look kind of
nud in these pants
you look kind of nude bottom line is we
need to eat proportionally and we need
to exercise and I think a great activity
would be
yoga you're an urge
man I had my wizard read his energy a
wizard they have like a little wand I
have a wizard and his energy but she was
spot on did she tell you I'm the most
beautiful man alive too she said he
needs to dream bigger and push his
boundaries he can do it he's an urge man
I'm an urge man I'm going to urge both
of you to go into this house so we can
find out if we're going to buy it
because I want to make some money uhoh
oh no the money it's a funu nightmare
all the money is going out the front
door this is a real thing Jeff so you're
telling me you're on fun S no not me and
you're on Wizards no no fun is real
Wizards are fake no no they're both real
funu is a real thing with buyers and if
the staircase is coming out the door
that means the money is running out of
the house and they're going to go broke
somebody lived in this house for 40 50
years all their money went out the door
dude so is reality TV just plain old we
show it with cameras and do whatever you
want to do man I just think that it's
really interesting to observe that that
I mean you you think of all the
Commandments that get broken all the
time and you just get used to it you're
just watching stuff with just like
nonsense yeah I mean I think this is a
case of these people are all into this
kind of stuff it's very common in Los
Angeles and you're going to see a lot of
stuff get put into TVs channels and and
shows because it's so common that that's
that's the point I'm making it is not
unscripted right and so this situation
right here Flip or Flop the last clip
that we saw it's not like she so happens
to walk up and tell them about the
wizard that she was seeing no it doesn't
work like that it's like hey so what
have you been up to lately oh you saw a
wizard that'll be kind of a fun segment
let's put that in there like I was
listening to a a audio book by um Jill
Dugger you know that the Dugger family
they were on TLC for many years 19 Kids
and Counting she grew up in reality
television and she basically wrote A
Memoir explaining it all and like the
trauma she experienced and how you know
it was really difficult for her to grow
up on TV the whole time and getting the
pressed to come after her and all that
stuff this one of the kids yeah she's an
adult now okay and she's explaining very
vividly look reality TV is super
scripted they they story producers that
that's part of one of the jobs that's
offered um on a lot of shows and what
they're they're doing is they're paying
attention to everything that's being
shot all the storyline that's going on
and then they're instigating that or
coring that if you would to make a
segment and some of some of them are
really good at their job and and but
it's it's it's interesting I mean a
person that I uh uh was friends with was
a story producer on um Divorce
Court how in the world is that like not
just something that happens that's real
but yeah there's story producers and
stuff like that that would yeah it's
it's warping your view of what reality
really is yeah I I I think like the
approach that I take with with with my
children especially like I'm very vocal
about things that I see that I
spiritually disagree with and um you you
know if something comes up they're you
know uh watching HDTV or something like
that and somebody says something you got
to bring it to their attention I think
that the more that you just let this
stuff slide and you don't say anything
and it's just like you know especially
with kids you don't have that
conversation with them they're getting a
message and it just gets reinforced over
the years so you know if you're going to
watch this kind of stuff just be aware
that there are things that you don't
agree with that are probably going to be
put in there have you guys ever been to
a party with a mind leer no no you have
I have yeah mind reader well I I think
that's what it's called but it's like an
Entertainer and they do things oh like a
psychic medium no wasn't the psychic
medium but just a mind reader psych
medium like what parties does K go to
asking questions and then like you know
pick a card type thing and he gets the
card or um they're asking certain
questions and in the beginning when he
was the man was asking the woman what
she look for in a man if he had the
exact two words that she was going to
say so that kind of stuff um so the
question I have is is there a difference
and if so what is between someone
reading someone's mannerisms or kind of
picking up on patterns and being able to
guess what someone's thinking versus a
spirit guide psychology that to me is
psychology it's science right there's a
science behind it which is realistic
well okay we know some science is very
in against what the Bible says is way
off but like you know and and generally
speaking I can appreciate and respect
Psych ology because it is based on
science whereas this spiritualism we
know from the Bible and I'm going to
pull this quote up later on that you are
not talking to your dead grandmother
right you're not talking to a dead
relative or whatever you're talking to
demons and spirits human psychology
right it was a movie that Will Smith was
in it was like a con movie you remember
what it was con movie and the the climax
of the movie was like it was a bet and
he had to pick which football player was
yes he was uh trying to help a guy with
his with his um relationship or
something no no not no not that one it
it was yeah what was it hitch hitch this
one was about betting it was about
gambling oh my and so how they won their
gamble their bets was to influence the
person that they were gambling with yeah
so pretty much uh the Crux of it or the
the climax was they were in they were at
a football game and the person had to
choose which player and then the guy who
was doing the gambling was to guess
which player that he chose I hope that
makes sense but all throughout the time
before the game on his way to the game
they're flashing the players's number on
screens they have like logos everywhere
so by the time he gets in the room all
of that ring his head so he's looking at
the field and he singles out that player
because of all thee yeah straight Brown
that's exactly what Dar Brown did I I
watched one where he went to the horse
races and and he goes I'm going to show
you that they will pay me out for a
losing ticket he walked straight up to
the guy and slap the ticket down I won
and the guy's like cool how much you win
he told told him or whatever like that
he peeled him off and then he walks away
with the money and then turns around and
goes back to the guy and goes why did
you give me money for a losing
ticket but it was because of the way
that he approached him so there's a lot
of psychology in and in you know making
people think certain things you can
influence people pretty pretty both
spiritual correct yeah yeah so uh
Christina Hall who we just saw a couple
times the blonde lady from California
after Flip or Flop uh well ended uh the
show like I said before she got two
shows on her own Christina on the coast
and Christina in the country she's
actually the producer of both of those
shows so when you think about that right
what do producers do for reality TV they
have they're like the big boss right
they have a huge influence on and what's
happening on the show so with
understanding that she uh is interested
in these things in their private life
it's not surprising that these things
show up in the show now some people
might say man what up with the crystals
like they're just showing you shots of
the crystals we'll come back to that
later on think of the psychological
effects that product placement has on
your brain right um and also I want to
point out that you know her being the
producer on the show there's also
directors who you know oversee all of
the camera work who also have to give
instructions like do close-ups with the
crystals and stuff so none of this is
just oh it just so happened like maybe
the camera operator liked the shop
because there's the sink she renovated
no there's a reason why it's in there
it's all scripted right um so like I
said before she is also interested in
these kind of things in her private life
and I found a video where she does a
tour of her home where she reviews some
of these things oh
hey HGTV Christine and Josh here Welcome
to our home come on in welcome to the
office it's where all the magic happens
oh yeah this is where the magic happens
I thought it was our
bedroom so this is probably the most
colorful room in the house we have a lot
of Blues of course we still have some
live plants that's an olive tree over
there I have this painting from one of
my wizard friends and of course my
favorite crystals the angel wing
amethyst amethyst yeah
but I just love all the natural light in
here just pop our laptop down take phone
calls have design
meetings it's a very relaxing office
yeah this is probably truly the only
room in the house that's actually for me
yeah well this is your space let's go
see
Myspace and you know it's mine that's
all your you stay out of there yeah this
like a lotus lotus Crystal Isis yeah
she's not hiding it yeah she talked
about Wizards and things like that think
about like the experience that Jesus had
when he was being tempted with Satan and
Satan's going look if you bow down to me
and you call me God or whatever I'll
give you all this stuff and I think
that's what's happening here in some of
these experiences I'll give you a Manion
getting Fame and success and then
they're tinkering with this stuff and
then they're they're attributing their
Fame and success to them bowing down to
whatever entity that is so the question
is do they know ah no no know the truth
I bet you they're deceived yeah a lot of
people say the devil I don't want to
make do and I don't want to make a
blanket statement like Christina Hall is
worshiping the devil and knows it I
don't want to say that you know but
she's definitely you know like falling
down this track maybe not even knowing
what she's tinkering with and it seems
like it's working for her because her
look she she went to see this
acupuncture lady and she got pregnant
when she couldn't get pregnant you know
what I mean so let's be clear though
there's only two sides you worship
Christ or you worship Satan and and he
has a lot lot of different disguises
whether it's yoga chakras tarot Ouija
whatever Corinthians 10 right it
basically says that uh those that
sacrificed they thought they were
sacrificing that they're actually
sacrificing to Demons yeah so you know
God loves Christina Hall he loves her
husband Josh Hall he loves anybody
working these Productions I want to make
it absolutely clear that despite them
tinkering the with these things God is
just constantly just working in their
hearts trying to pull them back that's
right pray for these people because they
are in a leadership position where
they're influencing a lot of people and
you know if you like home Fixit shows
and you are you know you know people
follow celebrities and they will have an
influence over a lot of people so pray
for these kind of people that that
somebody's around them can reach them
with the truth that's right shout out to
Kat Von D keep grat Von D go for
it yeah so so you you talked earlier you
talked a little bit about how in reality
TV you know these people especially in
California are interested in
spiritualism New Age these kind of
topics and that's why we tend to see it
in these kind of programs especially if
those people are at the top like the
producers the directors Etc so I found a
clip well we all found this ages ago
that really uh reveals the intent of
these people at the top uh so let's take
a look at that one um so I I always like
to think of it as like I've got him
sitting there whip a little message at
him whip a little moral at him whip a
little of what my view of the world is
because that's what every good filmmaker
does Okay Kevin Smith Hollywood director
right I know this is Hollywood this is
not reality TV and he basically says
these are my ideas my morality and I'm
going to put this in my movies and put
my worldview in these movies right now
what about reality TV
so this is this is Ria May Brown she is
an author this is what she writes art is
moral passion married to entertainment
moral passion without entertainment is
propaganda and entertainment without
moral passion is television in other
words television is propaganda let's
look at one more quote this is Annette
Hill professor of media and research and
she says reality TV seems to lack a
moral Center by which viewers can check
their own moral compass now I want to
hang on that for a second because what
what what I think is going on here with
reality television um you know the devil
influences a lot of people just as much
as God influences a lot of people too
right you you're operating under the
spirit of God you don't have the spirit
of God you could easily be operating
under a demonic Spirit that's
influencing you in a certain way and um
what I believe that you're doing is
you're seeing
a lot of immoral humanity and you're
seeing that as reality and they call it
reality I mean isn't that just a crazy
thing that there're that they're I mean
it's almost like calling it like life
this is what life looks like and then as
people are watching that what you don't
realize is you're watching an extreme
view of Brokenness or immorality that's
not really representative of of Life as
a whole reality defeat doesn't have a
moral Center so your you as you're
trying to figure out what your moral
should be reality TV is not going to
depict good morality you can't find it
there what do we understand our moral
compass to be as Christians the Bible
the Bible exactly does reality TV in any
way shape or form depict Christianity
according to the scriptures right no no
right it does the opposite and so that's
why it is such a problem when we watch
these things because it really leaves us
astray yeah you're watching immorality
and then it's like it's like it's like
monkey see monkey do right well I'm not
that bad or must be okay or you're yeah
you're just you know you're just living
up to the standards that you're watching
yeah is how I kind of interpreted that
right that's what I think too like we
were talking about the degradation of
Morality In television you got leave at
the beaver and all that and Full House
gets caught drinking half a beer and
I'll never drink again Dad and now it's
like here put some hair on your chest
and now it's like oh it must be okay to
share a beer with your son 10-year-old
son because I saw it on TV and it's
normal you have actors who don't have
TVs in their home we have musicians who
don't play their music for their
children at least not to their adults
well adults um but we're so quick as as
a society to be like here here here or
not be as attentive to our children are
doing but as morality is degrading and
as it's falling apart I think it is so
amazing that God does his best work in
the most unreal immoral situation he
like it says in Revelation right here is
a people that have no guile in their
mouth here is a group that literally
like are are you know full of
righteousness and they love not their
lives even unto death like that's the
picture that God wants to take
Christianity in the face of where this
is all going so whatever we're talking
about right now also shows up science
right these things these things that we
behold on the TV with no uh moral Center
affect us psychologically and
neurologically so let's take a look at
the next clip the name mirror neuron
comes from the fact that they fire both
when you do something and when you watch
someone doing something even if you like
don't move a muscle basically it's as if
they mirror the neural activity of the
person actually doing the thing in other
words by beholding we become changed but
we all with unveiled face beholding as
in a mirror the glory of the Lord are
being transformed into the same image
from glory to glory just as by the
spirit of the Lord mirror neurons uh you
also talked about it in documentary
pseudology The Art of Lying go check it
out on our Vimeo where you can rent this
whole documentary um talks about media
on the brain we we spent uh almost a two
to three years traveling around
interviewing neurologists scientists
doctors um all kinds of different people
about the effects that TV has on brains
especially young children's that are
developing um and that that we put a lot
of great energy into that so if you are
very curious about the mechanics of how
TV works I really highly suggest that
you can even just look in our YouTube
channel and just search we'll put a link
to the description of the of the um
trailer that's on there but it's good
information to know and you will be
shocked at how how much they actually
really do know they know that that
there's an influence and an effect right
so literally like this clip was saying
and by the way this clip is from uh a
video we did on the Barbie movie which
you can find on our YouTube um it's
saying monkey see monkey do when if you
go and please don't do that but if you
punch candy or something like that right
my brain cannot tell the difference it
makes it make my brain thinks that that
I just did that basically right it
cannot determine that I didn't but it
was you doing it it doesn't separate the
two simp exactly and that's why the
Bible says the Bible was way ahead of
its time it says but we all with
unveiled face beholding as in a mirror
the glory of the Lord are being
transformed into the same image from
glory to glory just as by the spirit of
the Lord in other words if we behold
Jesus we become changed into His Image
but if we behold evil immorality we
become changed into that that's why that
song says turn your eyes to G you know
Turn Your Eyes Upon Jesus that's right
right because if you look into his
wonderful face the things of this world
will grow strangely dim in the light of
his glory and grace and if you focus on
all this evil
trash you will eventually lean towards
that if you focus on and keep your eyes
on a relation ship with Jesus you will
eventually want to become like Jesus you
guys heard of the frontal lobe yeah can
somebody explain quickly what it is
what's what's the frontal Lo the seat of
your morality spirituality and your will
it's your uh computer driving force but
it's also where God interacts with you
that's right sits right in your forehead
what's behind the frontal Lo what part
of the
brain canas no lyic system lyic system
way you know what the lyic system does
lizard brain it's your emotional brain
well that's what the evolutionists call
it but yeah yeah fight or flight
anger
aggression that's where survival surv
that's where you get your sexual passion
from Etc um so I've got a clip in here
that explains it a little bit more and
this is from pseudology if you've ever
experienced a mind fog after watching
television you're not alone the brain
has four modes that it operates in four
brain wave pth patterns Delta is when
you're deep asleep Theta is when you're
in light sleep Alpha is awake but
relaxed it's the mode of of thinking
that you are in when you're in the most
heightened state of suggestibility and
then there's beta the highest
functioning mode like when you're
reading a book or you're having a very
stimulating
conversation in 1969 Herbert Krugman did
a study where he found that in less than
60 seconds the human brain switched from
beta brain wave patterns those exhibited
during logical thought to Alpha Brain
Wave patterns that's a awesome
documentary as an influencer I want to
recommend watching pseudology like out
of all the documentaries that little
light has pseudology and replacement
Gods part one are like
topnotch Timeless pieces it doesn't
matter how old it this is amazing
information and this is something that
if somebody's a skeptic like not a
Christian even yeah I don't believe
science media has an influence on me
when you watch this you're going to know
that media does have an influence on you
and then you say okay now that you've
accepted that it has an influence what
are you watching what's the message
you're getting over and over and over
again yep and that's my brother Tom by
the way yeah
Tom Yeah so basically um if you watched
media besides the mirror neurons besides
you know monkey see monkey do there's
also this aspect of the frontal lobe
which is the seat of morality
spirituality the will the part of your
brain used to make thorough thought out
decisions is shut off right and the lyic
system takes over the aggression the I
don't know sexual passions and all that
kind of stuff now moving on from this
point right understanding a little bit
of the mechanics of the brain what about
if we see those crystals uh just put
around but nobody talks about it which
we could connect to product plac what
about product placement what kind of
effect does that have on the brain
psychologically when we're exposed to a
persuasion attempt and we recognize it
as a persuasion attempt your defenses
automatically go up we don't have the
same reaction necessarily with product
placement if it's incorporated into the
programming that we're interested in
that's especially true if it's done in a
way that fits you know in the Marvel
movies Audi provides many of the
vehicles so Tony Stark driving you know
an Audi uh Supercar we don't think
anything of it the integration it's much
more subtle it doesn't come across as
that blatent persuasion
attempt data suggests that this type of
advertising is extremely effective in a
2018 study by branded Entertainment
Network a major player in this type of
marketing they found that product
placement is 11% more effective in
driving purchases and 10% more effective
in supporting brand Affinity over
traditional 302 commercials and on Hulu
specifically those numbers reach 89% and
74% man whoa that's that's really like
true because when a commercial comes on
people like mute it walk away you don't
even want to watch it because you're
like you're just trying to sell me
something but when you're wrapped up in
the story wrapped up in the movie and
you see your favorite celebrity like
rocking that thing they look so good in
it you're like man I want a car like
that has a story about that do
you you talking about the the fur coat
yes oh yeah was that so when I was in
Hollywood um I'll have to dig up the um
picture sometime for you but um oh I can
find I was a I was a big fan of Fight
Club and in their Brad Pit wore a fur
coat so I mean I jumped in the car and
went straight down to the local thrift
shop and bought a fur coat I was like
yeah this is this is this pimp dude a
fur coat in La that madean a lot of s
the fur coat out I mean I just think I
needed to have my head examined at that
point but speaking of Fight Club there's
a clip is it in pseudology or some of
your presentations where where you asked
you were showing Fight Club at a
Christian college and asked them
afterwards so where did you hear them
cussing out God and like one person
raised their hand and that and that
really speaks to um the what you just
mentioned about the way the mind works
um because your computer your brain is
like a computer it can only process the
information so fast you're throwing a
lot of information at them when you're
watching a movie there's sounds Cuts
there's different storylines that are
going on you're trying to make sense of
like who's this who's that but they're
not showing you a sequential time frame
it's like all this stuff Blended
together and so your brain to compensate
for that works off of your lyic system
and you're not thinking critically about
any information going in well in the
middle of that movie fight club or and
the most emotional scene Brad Pit slaps
Edward Norton says you have to consider
the possibility that God does not like
you in fact God hates you we don't need
God we don't need salvation we don't
need Redemption and he goes on this
whole monologue about how much God hates
you our fathers were our models for God
if our fathers bailed what does that
tell you about God no no I don't listen
to me you have to consider the
possibility that God does not like you
never wanted you in all probability he
hates you this is not the worst thing
that can happen it isn't we don't need
him we don't damn Nation man Redemption
we are God's unwanted children so be it
there a f listen you can run water over
your hand to make it worse or look at me
or you can use vinegar to neutralize the
burn please let me have it please first
you have to give up first you have to
know not fear know and someday you're
going to die you don't know how this
feels it's only after we've lost
everything that we're free to do
anything and it's like
where did God come into this picture
like like this was out of left field so
when I asked all those kids there was
probably 400 kids Plus in the room um
who's seen this movie a bunch of hands
went up and I said where do they talk
about God one hand in the back went up I
want to ask a quick question I have seen
this movie probably 20 times maybe more
this was one of my favorite
films how many people in this room have
seen this movie look at how many hands
just went up can somebody tell me in
this movie where they speak about
God you got one
person what
scene one person all of you people
raised your hand and only one person
told me when they talk about God and so
out of 400 people one hand could
remember the part where they talk about
God is
staggering um to really observe like
this is the power that this media has
clearly goes in your brain's a recorder
of pictures all those pictures they it
it records all that stuff but but the
ability to think about it and make a
decision about it isn't always there but
that seed sits in the back of your mind
you watch enough of those seeds like
brand placement over time you'll be
influenced by that brand I mean I mean
it literally said that according to Hulu
there was an 89% increase of brand
Affinity that is a lot just from product
placement so if you just put crystals in
almost every single episode and there's
already a fan base or an emotional
attachment to this to this individual
who's presenting the show I mean come on
and remember people are watching the
show to get ideas on how to how to put
their house so I wonder if Crystal sales
go up or something like that because of
all the stuff that's in there but yeah
it's another case of God creating
something beautiful him creating
something perfect and then Satan coming
in and manipulating it for evil because
God wants us to experience pleasure life
should be pleasurable but Satan is
taking that pleasure and then also
putting you in an instance where you
should be thinking but now you're
overtaken by Pleasure whenever God is
trying to interact with us what does he
say come let us reason together I'm not
going to try to manipulate you I'm not
going to over stimulate your pleasure
let's actually have a conversation and
talk that's right that's not the tactic
of the devil and we need to be mindful
of that yeah that's right that's right
so to kind of pull this all together
right we understand the the mechanics of
the brain we understand this 100% has an
influence in us whether we like it or
not it it affects us
psychologically uh and in any other way
so why does this matter as a Christian
or even for people who are not Christian
let's look at some Bible verses here so
this is Deuteronomy 1810 and 11 there
shall not be found among you anyone who
makes his son or his daughter pass
through to fire or one who practices
witchcraft or a soothsayer or one who
interprets Omens or sorcerer or one who
conjures spells or a medium or
spiritists or one who calls up the dead
it's pretty clear to me yeah yeah very
specific very specific uh 2 Chronicles
336 also he Manasseh king of Judah
caused his sons to pass through the fire
in the Valley of the son of hinm he
practiced Su saying used Witchcraft and
sorcery and consulted mediums and
spiritists heed did much evil in the
sight of the Lord to provoke him to
anger and I've got one more here is a
little bit longer this is from 1st
Samuel 28: 3 and 7-15 people are usually
pretty familiar with these verses so it
says now Samuel had died and all Israel
had lamented for him and buried him in
Rama in his own City and Saul had put
the mediums and the spiritists out of
the land then Saul said to his servants
find me a woman who is a medium that I
may go to her and inquire of her and his
servants said to him in fact there is a
woman who is a medium at Endor so Saul
disguised himself and put on other
clothes and he went and two men with him
and they came to the woman by night and
he said please conduct a seance for me
and bring up for me the one I shall name
to you then the woman said to him look
you know that s what Saul has done how
he has caught off the mediums and the
spiritists from the land why then you
lay a snare for my life to cause me to
die and Paul swore to her by the Lord
saying as the Lord lives no punishment
shall come upon you for this thing then
the woman said whom shall I bring up for
you and he said bring up Samuel for me
when the woman saw Samuel she cried out
with a loud voice and the woman spoke to
Saul saying why have you deceived me for
you are Saul and the King said to Hero
not be afraid what did you see and the
woman said to Saul I saw a spirit
ascending out of the earth so he said to
her what is his form and she said an old
man is coming up and he is covered with
a mantle and Saul perceived perceived
that it was Samuel and he stooped with
his face to the ground and bowed down
who was Saul speaking to it's pretty
clear to me and clear in according to
the scriptures that this was a spirit
right and we see this too in um
Revelation where it says for they are
spirits of demons performing signs which
go out to the kings of the earth and of
the whole world to gather them to the
Battle of that great day of God Almighty
yep I've heard a lot of Christians
believe that that was a real incident
they said well how do you you know
because we understand when you're dead
you're dead until the resurrection
that's why it's a resurrection that's
why you're coming out of the Grave CU
you're still there yeah um and any
anybody any communication with the dead
is necromancy it's uh it's demonic
deception familiar spirits and I've
heard many Christians say well how do
you explain Saul seeing Samuel well for
one he perceived it for another he was
an old man I don't think when you die as
a righteous Samuel you're going to come
up old for another you shouldn't be
coming up from anywhere if you're in
heaven yeah so there's a lot of things
and and it you highlight the word Spirit
but in if you go to the original Hebrew
or Greek but Hebrew it says Elohim she
saw Elohim rising out of the earth she's
seeing like demonic figures like fallen
angels are Elohim you know these gods
and things she he wasn't seeing Samuel
he was seeing Samuel but it wasn't
Samuel but even with that arguing that
point is missing the overall point there
was consequences for him doing that
there was a curse there was punishment
so it shouldn't be done you made me one
more point because if this is true for
all Christians that believe this is true
you're honestly believing that a witch
can say some magic spell and pull up
dead people from wherever God has placed
them Heaven hell Purgatory Shield
whatever you believe you actually
believe that a witch has the power to
say some magic word and pull that Spirit
from where God has placed them that is
crazy more powerful excellent point and
and you know I was just sitting there
listening to you talk there and I said
you know isn't it funny that the demons
they can't even counterfeit something
that if it was true like in the that
real manner demons are smart right so
don't you think like they're if they're
thinking okay this guy died and we know
that that you know he's not in heaven
but we're going to make him look like he
comes from Heaven because the cultures
down the road are going to read this and
see that he came down from heaven they
can't do that there's some sort of rules
or laws or whatever like this they had
to make him come out of the ground and
like you said he's an old man he came
out of the ground there's so many red
flags here to why he did not come from
God that was not Samuel yeah that Saul's
story reminds me of this point that the
choice is Moment by moment the same King
who banned this practice who outlawed
them who killed all the witches is the
same King now looking for a witch to
conjure up the man of God so exactly so
it's not okay I I did this in my past so
I'm good to go for the rest of my life
it's a daily
connection with Christ it's a daily
decision Moment by decision to follow
the principles in the Bible and they
told him the truth yeah they said you're
going the wi was witnessing to him want
to do this yeah you're going to die
right or did they understand the
mechanics of when we place ourselves on
the Devil's Ground the devil can have
his way with us we're outside of God's
protection at that point and so if he
went okay Saul just just stepped outside
of God's complete protection God's going
to back off you know the devil knows God
and the way that God would react to any
situation he knows God better than
anyone else and so then he said he will
be mine and will take him out at that
moment M but he didn't kill himself
right he killed himself but there was
enemy coming towards him and I mean he
would have died consider the sphere of
influence so he died his son died they
lost the war and three of his sons right
didn't say three of them went down with
him on possi and he watched them die I
think is what the Bible says yeah that's
rough so let's go back to Christina Hall
where she is talking to a psychic medium
which is pretty much what Samuel did
right here in the
Bible
hi hi chrisa great to meet
Christina when Christina opened the door
I did not recognize her but I could tell
that she was a little nervous going to
the experience which I felt on the way
here you can have a seat right here
awesome we'll do behind the scenes today
are two of my very best girlfriends they
know everything about me um and they are
also big Tyler fans have you ever had a
reading have you ever seen a medium I've
never had one and I've always wanted one
super excited very cool a little bit of
direction from Beyond would be really
meaningful right now um objects can
sometimes help me kind of gravitate more
towards certain people and what I'll do
is I'll just kind of scribble we'll see
what comes through I'm going to hold on
to an object and we'll see what connects
this is a letter okay
[Music]
cool
okay there's you you
o there's a reference to like mental
cognizance it's this woman who's
acknowledging that like she's bringing
this much more to my like brain my
cognizance my awareness and the thing is
she's showing me secrecy around this
which is someone's way of saying like
I'm trying to like not show that I'm
forgetting things or that I'm not all
there but it's almost a feeling of like
being evasive or like trying to cover it
this is just a woman who was like no oh
like I don't want you to focus on on me
and what's going on with me I just want
to like be happy
with so my grandma she's like by far the
person who I was closest to she started
going through
Alzheimer's her name was Mildred but she
hated it so she went by biddy Grandma
biddy uh me and her were so close we
used to talk on the phone almost every
other day and when I'd go visit her we'd
actually stay up all night sometimes
talking yeah yeah so we have a huge
connection
[Music]
um family coming in on that
side oh
no no I'm going to run and go grab it
real quick I'll be right back no worries
we'll hold on to this
[Music]
okay that's a first all right slightly
important okay obviously like I want to
be able to get as much information as
possible that's relevant to you and the
here and the now right so I want to
focus on Grandma um your grandma is
putting an extra emphasis in these past
two years for some reason of like being
around you a lot and I don't know why
this is coming in
okay I don't know I can hear my Glam
laughing I need to tell
you she's having me talk about change
transition
like transitions changes things and then
she's having me talk about like take a
deep breath you're getting things
together you're moving forward I don't
know what this is but it's like take a
deep breath you're going to be okay like
we're moving forward now okay that makes
perfect
sense okay it just seems very emotional
as the way that I would describe this um
I'm just trying to very emotional
yeah but I need to know that whatever
this is being referred to your grandma
is behind this in a way that I can't
even begin to verbalize the amount of
support that's there is so strong and
the feeling is like picking up the
pieces is really the visual that she's
showing me it's like you're going to
pick up the pieces you're going to be
okay they referring this feeling of like
you're moving forward and there's going
to be so much to look forward to and you
need to know that as
well so uh show that I've been doing for
the past 5 years uh we're on season 7
right now it's called flipper Flop on
HGTV okay I do it with my soon Tobe
ex-husband nice
yeah I see okay I got
[Music]
you I got you I'm so sorry it's okay
when my divorce went down and it was so
public um it caused a rift between my
parents and myself I think they were
very proud of everything that my ex and
I had built and I think they were very
scared of what the future
held for me and it caused us to drift
apart when we were pretty close so I was
just sort of hoping there was some sort
of message maybe from my grandma who
both my dad and I were close with as far
as like what she sees with that Dynamic
with my parents and myself the way that
this is coming in is to show patience
around this Dad that that'll work itself
out the mom situation you're going to
just kind of have to step back I think
that there will be an opportunity for
that to be mended over the next two
years what's ironic is that's basically
what I've told her yeah it makes me feel
better that um I'm hearing that it's
okay to give it more time because that's
kind of where I'm at I don't want to
rush it or force it and I feel like you
know time heals all so I'm glad that
that message is being repeated thank you
so much absolutely you blew my mind for
sure so wonderful to me so much than
this reminds me I I did a video because
Brad he had done a video on uh Brad Pit
you mean
or wait who you talk about okay Brad
that used to work here oh Brad Pit we
fired him a long a genuine question oh
wow we're talking about celebrities Brad
my boy Brad Brad Pit Brad Pit if you're
watching please come on our Channel yeah
yeah we need it bro when Brad was
working here he made a video showing
clip after clip of like the Kardashians
and all these celebrities talking to
spiritualism spiritualist and so I did
one that was all Christian people
talking about Steve Harvey Oprah you
know she even claims to be a Christian
Kelly Clarkson who's a Christian who
have spiritualist on their show Drew
Barrymore U and and the spiritualist is
saying like oh your your dead mother's
saying this or what oh the Sabrina
Teenage Witch Melissa jonart and in
seconds the spiritualist could let their
guard down I mean Melissa jonart was
like I've heard some things in the Bible
about talking to the dead and he's like
oh no no no no that was people that they
were Pagan worshippers and all that I'm
a Christian and she's like oh I'm so
glad let's do this like that quick and
so I I put that video on YouTube ETV
gave us a really hard time about those
clips even though I chopped them up a
lot I'm going to work really hard to get
that back on YouTube right now you can
watch it on our Odyssey if you know what
that is I'll put a link in the
description to look at that video but
this just this is happening in the
Christian world the Christians are being
deceived about talking to the dead
necromancy this is why you want to
subscribe to our channel so that when
Mikey finishes this video we don't know
when it'll be done but you'll get
notified right when that hit the Bell
icon video hits the scene so if you
haven't please subscribe to our Channel
it really helps us out and it helps you
out too because you'll get good
information that's right speaking of
Christians Christina Hall found a clip
where she says she's a Christian let's
take a look welcome to Jesus Calling
stories of faith our guest is star of
hgtv's Flip or Flop Christina anstead
she shares how the moment from both her
successes and her Dark Days led her back
to Wellness and a new journey toward
God
so after the divorce there was a series
of things that happened that were like
straight from God and they're so
personal that maybe when I'm like 90
I'll talk about them but um it led me to
start going to church and the messages
that I was being sent spiritually were
the same messages I was getting at
church and and it was it actually made
me be able to relax a little bit when
everything else was so crazy and there
was so much commotion like in the
physical world wow why am I putting this
in here because you know as a Christian
she is she's has a desire to get to know
the Lord right she's clearly wanting to
seek truth she's even went start going
to church after her divorce which was a
couple of years ago but unfortunately
she's also dabbling with the new age and
all these things and I think it's
important to put this specific video out
there specifically for Christians
because watching these things opening
your heart to these things is creating a
slippery slope you give the devil a
crack and he will pull it open wide and
he will come and try to do whatever he
can to take control of your heart and
that is so sad but you're talking about
these other celebrities as well Jesus
loves all of them he loves Christin a
hall but unfortunately there's a lot of
confusion and this confusion starts as
soon as you give the devil just a little
bit and he will he will come and confuse
your mind this is what Chris Lang's
documentary is about mystified I'd
highly recommend you check it out it's
free on YouTube we actually link it in
the description of this video but he's
talking about Christian genuine
Christian um not just actually not just
Christians people from different faiths
and walks of life coming together in
this ecumenical movement and this push
but really the the at the base of it is
spiritualism at the base of it is
crystals and these things that they
thought were so innocent but it pulled
them out of the religion that they were
in and now they're a lot further than
when they started and wasn't one of the
guys that was in it from Los Angeles yes
y real that point I mean they are all
literally surrounded by this kind of
stuff and that's why I think you're
seeing a lot of this in these kind of
Productions but I think it's also so
doubly damaging to have somebody who's
got all this spiritualism involved and
then saying that they're Christian as if
they're blending it and saying that this
is okay to have your fingers in all this
other kind of stuff where I don't
believe that's okay you cannot serve two
masters those are two masters the
Bible's very clear about that you're
going to love one and hate the other or
you're just going to you know yeah and
and and we're not saying like uh you
know woe is her or whatever we're
blaming her again these people are
confused
and theyy everybody is born with in to
truth and and that's why you see so many
so many of these spiritualistic things
everywhere because people are
understanding people are trying to
understand where did I come from where
am I going and it's just sad that some
people um get things mixed up even
mixing Christianity with
spiritualism and this is where they uh
you know end up but they never are able
to find the peace that they're looking
for and how much worship is interwoven
into Humanity you're worshiping
something absolutely so you might want
to make sure you're worshiping the right
thing this is why we talk about these
topics on this channel though as a new
Christian myself uh in 2005 I was being
told by Christians like hey you got all
the girls like King Solomon you know
Jesus turned water and wine drink up
every Green nerve bearing seed be used
for me and so I was living my lifestyle
based on what I was being told and then
I as an artist I love religious art even
as someone who wasn't a Christian I
collected religious art I still had
those things in my home when I became a
Christian and a guy came my
ex-girlfriend's dad came over and was
studying the Bible with me he's like I
don't know if you should have all that
stuff Buddha and a goat and all this I'm
like oh I don't worship it it's just you
know I just like religious art I just
you know but it I did get convicted the
more I read the Bible and I seen like
how much God is against idolatry I threw
those things away I still had a Ouija
board I still played with tarot two
times after being a Christian and all
because there wasn't somebody saying
look this is wrong and this is why and
that's what we try to do on this channel
we don't want to just say don't do it
because I said so like some people's
parents do we want to show you look this
is dangerous and we're going to show you
every reason why we see the danger now
it's up to you and the Holy Spirit pray
this out and we hope that you make the
right decision yeah this is we're living
in the last days of much deception many
people the dragon's going to deceive the
whole world that's a big number and it's
all starting with stuff like this I'm a
Christian I don't just have crystals I
have false idols and uh lotuses and
talking to wizards I mean she's like
deep it's not just a crystal on her
counter right this is straight up new
age doing yoga with your kids and
acupuncture and this is where we're at
so we hope that this is like a warning
to people of how massive this deception
is and where it's seeping into the
church yeah Babylon was king of taking
over different entities throughout
history and then instead of basically
just saying you now have to follow
everything Babylonian they would soak up
all their gods and soak up all their
religions and then say oh it's okay you
can kind of blend that together but it's
like this amalgamation and it was it
caused spiritual confusion and there has
been churches in in history church I
should maybe say dropped the s that also
did that soaked up all this other kind
of religious paganism and then kind of
rebranded it and said it's okay you can
still practice all these things but but
but really you can still be a part of
the church so you know do a little study
do a little digging into that um if you
have some questions we want to hear
about them in the description below but
um amen let's look at one more clip this
is fascinating to me when I saw this
this lady uh was a former witch I'm not
going to going to um give you guys a
little Cliffhanger or anything let's
just Dive Right In CU this is a super
cool clip and super cool
testimony I watched the movie and I
thought I want that well of course in
the movie they went too far anyway and
the Witchcraft had turned against them
and the girls were desperate to get out
of it but during that point I didn't
even see that ending I just thought oh I
won't go that far I'm just going to be
innocent in it and I began to study the
religion of Wiccan and study um
different spells and incantations and
New Age practices and occult practices
that I was doing in a Christian home
that nobody knew I was doing and so what
started off as something innocent where
I'm just connecting with energy and the
universe and Vibes and all these
innocent things that we see took me down
a path of just dark
desperation um I I felt at one point
that I was living in like a h haunted
house because I was hearing scratches on
the wall right next to me I would feel
brushed by me and be terrified as
somebody is here in the room with me
someone's watching me I've always felt
like I was being watched when I would
wash my face for the day it was one of
the most terrifying things that I did
when I took a shower and I had to close
my eyes I was so terrified if I had to
get up in the middle of the night to get
a glass of water I would run because I
thought something's going to grab my
feet I was an adult at this point and it
took me far into drugs um I ended up
being homeless and on drugs in and out
of jails and all kinds of things for n
years of my life I was really in a dark
place I think media has done a good job
of pushing something to the point where
it is now normalized when back in the
day something like that for you and I it
would be shocking to
see
and now because we have shows as early
as you know daycare age promoting
Witchcraft and sorcery and it's okay
boys and girls say these spell words
with us and it's so ABC preschool
witchcraft that it gets into the hearts
and the minds of people including the
people in church and people who are are
not really connected with the Lord and
don't understand they're easily deceived
and the Bible talks about even the very
elect will be deceived and so people are
going to a whole another source that's
what they're they're wanting they want a
healing Crystal because they don't
understand that Jesus is the Healer and
there's no other source that you can go
to except through Jesus and so I I'm
seeing a rise of this I'm seeing it
become very trending on Tik Tok and
things like that and there's a whole
generation of people who I feel like are
being rocked asleep by the enemy and
it's just really time for the church
like what you're doing doing this
interview to sound the alarm and say no
we need to wake up and we need to say
this is not right it's not for my home
it's not for my kids wow powerful I know
mhm we have kind of a bit of a
discussion about Witchcraft and stuff on
ongoing discussion in my home and my
kids know if it's got witchcraft in it
we leave it completely alone doesn't it
matter how cool you think the story is
or whatever you think you're going to
learn from this thing the Witchcraft we
draw a heavy line yeah what I find
powerful is that she uh got into
witchcraft because of one kid's movie
called The Craft children's oh is it is
not a kids movie Teen Movie okay so so
those are the kind of movies that people
think other but they're so innocent
right and it's the same with these HGTV
TLC whatever things it's so innocent
it's just it's literally just Crystal
sitting there or well they're talking to
a psychic medium but look it's with the
pets with her dog and but it that's what
got her into it that got her into to be
homeless to be depress to be
suicidal I mean that is crazy to me and
she's now warning people now that she's
a Christian saying don't do this and she
was raised in a Christian home you know
and but what I find so beautiful is that
she says you will not find peace in
crystals you will not find peace in any
of these paintings or um in the yoga or
whatever it is right it it's in Jesus
and so I do want to encourage people at
home if you're into these things look to
Jesus open up a Bible go to a go to a
thrift store or a bookstore and just and
and get get yourself a Bible or even
look on your phone and see if this piece
that you're looking for that you're not
finding in in any of these things the
new age the spiritualism the Witchcraft
the wizard
try Jesus because you know Mikey was in
the occult ones and and what is it like
Satanism he said Terra cards and
everything and he couldn't find it there
but then his final stop stop was Jesus
right I have a couple of verses on the
screen as well this is from John it says
Jesus said to him I am the way the truth
and the life no one comes to the father
except through me and from Philippians
it says and the peace of God which
thepass was all understanding will guard
your hearts and Minds through Christ
Jesus amen it's true you can try all
these different Avenues but eventually
they come to a dead end and a rock
bottom there's no peace no hope and
you're just left like what what what's
left you know and usually it's Christ
because
we that's the one thing that we push
away we push away God we push away Jesus
no you want to change my life and all
these things But ultimately when you try
all these other things you're going to
find out he's the answer and so just
take it from from me don't go down this
pass what do you have to lose yeah give
it a try what do you have to lose if you
if you've never given it a serious try
you stumbled across this video this the
first time you've ever been introduced
to this kind of a a topic and I don't
know whatever maybe you were intrigued
by the spiritualism aspect of of reality
television but what are you going to
lose if you literally say Okay God I'm
going to give you a shot and just like
the Bible says taste and see that the
Lord is good right you will not be sorry
I think we're all in agreeance here that
we've had our own walks and points where
we've met Jesus and looking at this
point I would never go back amen that's
right yeah so should you not watch any
reality TV should you not watch HGTV or
maybe you know a home renovation show I
leave it up to your own discretion
prayerfully with the Lord
um I know for myself specifically
Christina on the coast I stopped
watching it I kept feeling uncomfortable
seeing the crystals and those kind of
things but you know there were other
shows where they didn't show up in and
that was just purely about home
renovation shows like like chip and
Joanna gains for example um but you know
that that's not to say that it will
never come up so really take it up to in
in prayer with the Lord and and let God
convict you on that other than that I
think that's the end of this show thank
you so much for watching please leave in
the comments below what your thoughts
are on this topic and maybe the Lord has
redeemed you please share it up because
it'll encourage other people also we
have T-shirts m scottyy is wearing a
really cool one the king is coming
revelation 22 verse2 if you want a
T-shirt and support this ministry you
can do so by going to lightwear do shop
um if you want to make a donation you
can do so on
ls. or
patreon.com Little Light Studios and you
also get some cool perks Mikey's got a
cool new YouTube channel what do you
have Mikey you guys need to check out
little light kids because the question
we get asked all the time is well what
can I watch you know what's safe for
kids we can't little light we can't put
a stamp of approval on anything I mean
would have approved Blues Clues and next
thing you know there's a drag queen it's
already happened so we want to actually
create content that's edifying
educational and points people to Christ
for kids so check out little like k kid
give it a subscribe help that channel
grow so we can grow the team and produce
more animations and things like that and
yeah thank you so much and if you'd like
to donate to little light kids you could
go to the same websites denique just
mentioned ls. little light studios. TV
and just specify that it's for little
light kids that's right also if you want
to learn more about the Bible we've got
a really cool podcast Little Light
Studios podcast you'll find it on any
podcasting app and we've got a free
online Bible School ls. TV v/b School
make sure you sign up and we'll see you
next time
bye if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little like
[Music]
kids
oh
[Music]